[Musik]
das hier ist die wiege des neuen krieges
zehn jahre nach der besetzung des iraks
durch amerikanische truppen steht das
land am rande eines bürgerkrieges
doch die welt nimmt kaum notiz davon
ulrich tilgner ist einer der wenigen
journalisten die noch regelmäßig aus dem
gefährlichen land berichten
wir begleiten den korrespondenten bei
seiner arbeit in diesem zerrissen und
land das auch nach dem ende der diktatur
saddam hussein nicht zur ruhe kommt
[Musik]
vor exakt zehn jahren am 20 märz 2003
machen die amerikaner ihre drohung wahr
und bombardieren bagdad
[Musik]
ulrich tilgner berichtet live aus dem
palast ein hotel
das alles ist ein teil des propaganda
krieges der irrtum seine jahrzehntelange
erfahrung im nahen osten hilft iltner
fakten und propaganda
auseinanderzuhalten
seit kriegsbeginn sind im irak 172
journalisten umgekommen
auch einer von täters mitarbeitern wurde
erschossen das hotel palestine bietet
keinen schutz
mit dem symbolischen sturz der statue
des diktators beginnt ein jahrelanges
chaos
[Musik]
bagdad heute von sams denkmal ist nur
noch der sockel übrig
wir begleiten ulrich tilgner zum
paradies platz vor zehn jahren ist hier
eine menschenverachtende diktatur zu
ende gegangen wir würden ullrich trainer
gerne an diesem symbolträchtigen ort
interviewen
doch unsere filmaufnahmen werden schon
nach wenigen sekunden von der polizei
gestoppt
[Musik]
ein steinwurf vom paradies platz
entfernt das paar ist ein hotel
journalisten logieren hier nur noch
selten
mein name ist hilke
ich habe 20 jahre lang in diesem hotel
gewohnt wiederbegegnung mit einem hotel
manager nach dem freundlichen empfang
hoffen wir vom hotel aus ein paar
filmaufnahmen machen zu können
doch zwei männer vom geheimdienst
stoppen die diskussion
es setzt sich die erkenntnis durch dass
journalisten in bagdad nicht willkommen
sind auch das ausgezeichnete kontakte
helfen nicht immer
die sternstunde dieses hotels so muss
man das sagen war der ki da waren die
journalisten da waren iraker hierher
geflohen die geld hat weil sie angst
hatten dass ihre häuser bombardiert
wurden
und jetzt ist das hotel restauriert
worden
die zimmer kann kaum noch jemand
bezahlen und das hotel ist er das haben
wir gesehen
während der ganzen zeit in bagdad
begegnen wir keinem einzigen westlichen
ausländer
die stadt präsentiert sich im
belagerungszustand alle 300 meter
sichern bewaffnete sicherheitskräfte die
straßen der stadt beschäftigt 700.000
männer in seinem sicherheitsapparat
terroranschläge zu verhindern dass die
terroristen sich nicht bewegen und in
die quartiere kommen können aber ist es
natürlich eine schau der macht eine
machtdemonstration und immer dann wenn
es gebraucht wird werden sie wieder da
sein und immer wenn es ruhig wird sind
sie weg während unserer woche in bagdad
explodieren drei sprengkörper attentate
mit dutzenden von toten
auch nach zehn jahren verfügt bagdad
über keine funktionierende infrastruktur
der von den amerikanern versprochene
wiederaufbau hat nie stattgefunden
das augenfälligste symbol für diese
misere ist das kabelgewirr das sich
durch fast alle straßen buck das sieht
strom aus dem offiziellen städtischen
netz gibt es nur ein paar stunden
täglich doch die iraker wissen sich zu
helfen und betreiben eigene generatoren
hier unterhält eine familie einen
größeren generator der imstande ist eine
ganze straße mit elektrizität zu
versorgen
herauszufinden welches kabel zu welchem
haushalt führt ist eine große kunst
stolz zeigen die strombacher den
korrespondenten ihre technik jedes
einzelne kabel geht zu einer familie
der besitzer erklärt dass er früher beim
staatlichen elektrizitätswerk gearbeitet
habe jetzt ist der private generator
eine wichtige einnahmequelle im ehemals
mausarm quartier die familie levels zu
tee ein
für ulrich tina eine gelegenheit etwas
über die lebensumstände der menschen zu
erfahren
der korrespondent möchte wissen wie sich
das leben seit saddam sturz verändert
hat im gegensatz zu früher können sich
die menschen orte frei äußern
die familienmitglieder kommen sofort auf
das leid zu sprechen dass sie während
der diktatur erlitten haben
jeder hier kannte jemanden der von
saddam schergen verschleppt oder getötet
wurde
in der familie gegeben die leute sind
verhaftet worden
einer hat sehr schön gesagt jemand wurde
hingerichtet und in der sagt man er sei
politisch gewesen er war gar nicht
politisch
leute die andere auffassung hatten
wurden hingerichtet die familie gehört
den schiitischen glauben an die schiiten
wurden in der diktatur des sunniten
saddam unterdrückt sie genießen heute
einen bescheidenen wohlstand und freie
meinungsäußerung facebook ist auch für
die jugend bagdad ein muss der größte
verkauf setting von stromausfällen
geplagten land sind ausgerechnet
elektrogeräte
während die staatliche infrastruktur
weiter zerfällt buhlt der private konsum
infrastrukturprojekte versandten in der
korruption
die schiitisch dominierte regierung
schaut machtlos zu auch die zahl der
autos hat sich verfügbar
doch weil der staat nicht die neue
straßen investiert kommt es täglich zum
verkehrskollaps
wo sich heute autos stauen sah es vor
zehn jahren noch so aus
sattel cottier dominierten immer wieder
amerikanische armee fahrzeuge des
straßen wind in soldaten riefen die
bevölkerung dazu auf ihre waffen
abzugeben
die amerikaner wurden nie als befreier
gefeiert im gegenteil sie wurden von
aufständischen jahrelang bekämpft
[Musik]
wir möchten wissen was von der
amerikanischen besetzung übrig geblieben
ist und fahren zu einem ehemaligen
stützpunkt die alten amerikanischen
wachtürme das sind jetzt iraker drin
natürlich aber das waren früher
amerikanische wachtürme
[Musik]
mitten in der wüste ein amerikanisches
dorf
[Musik]
irakische offiziere führen uns durch den
verlassenen stützpunkt
[Musik]
ist das wasser sehr märkten haben jeden
tag sie mussten sich das trio vor liter
dose order politik
sie mussten vier liegt
das ist das selbstverständnis der
amerikanischen kriegsführung hier was
soll das hier ein antrag da so ein
ungeziefer dass er hat symbolkraft so
ein bild hat eine unglaubliche
symbolkraft
das ist der panzer hier kommen die hier
kommen die amerikaner an das ist das ist
dass die amerikanischen kriegsmaschine
ist das ungeziefer hängt an bagdad so
unglaublich die flüsse euphrat und
tigris teilen den irak und sorgen den
wüstenstaat für einen streifen
fruchtbarkeit
doch an ihren ufern leben menschen die
ganz unterschiedlichen kulturen
angehören kurden sunniten schiiten
korrespondenz tilgner hat sich
vorgenommen auch diesmal alle drei
landesteile zu besuchen
er möchte nur über das berichten was er
mit eigenen augen gesehen hat
vor der reise entschieden gebiet genießt
er ein frühstück bestehend aus bohnen
eiern und brot
tilgner ist 65 jahre alt und vater
zweier erwachsener kinder
auf der fahrt könnten über große bilder
von geistlichen würdenträgern und
schwarze fahnen das spirituelle zentrum
des schäden gebietes an
wie sieht nun die sunniten kämpfen um
die macht im irak
es geht um die öleinnahmen wie sie
verteilt werden
und sie haben jetzt die
auseinandersetzung dass die sunniten von
der macht verdrängt wurden durch den
sturz von saddam hussein
und jetzt versuchen zumindest es ein
teil dieser macht zurückzugewinnen
nadschaf ist für die schiiten eine
heilige stadt wird von tausenden pilgern
besucht
[Musik]
die moscheen wurden schon mehrmals ziel
von selbstmordattentätern
deshalb will die der besucher
kontrolliert
aber warten wir nun erstmal fahren
nadschaf ist doch für die glaubensbrüder
im iran eine heilige stätte
weltweit gehören ein viertel aller
moslems dem schiitischen glauben an die
schiiten sind im irak in der mehrheit
und stellen auch die ministerpräsidenten
entsprechend selbstbewusst geben sich
heute die religionsvertreter
ulrich tilgner hat einen termin bei
vorsteher der moschee der nahost experte
spricht nur wenig arabisch fremdsprachen
sei nicht seine stärke sagt er
doch obwohl er auch übersetzer
angewiesen ist findet er sofort den
draht zu seinen gesprächspartnern
ich kenne den irak osterzeit stamms wenn
ich diese mit der heutigen zeit
vergleiche dann ist der größte
unterschied die religionsfreiheit
[Musik]
er hat gesagt wenn es da dam noch gäbe
würden wir alle im gefängnis sitzen
und das hat am morgen gab es ja nicht
nur eine politische unterdrückung
sondern auch eine gewaltige religiöse
unterdrückung und die schiiten waren
besonders betroffen wenn sie sich
religiös betätigt haben dann wurde das
gleich als politischer widerstand
gewährte das neue selbstbewusstsein der
schiiten zeigt sich auch beim bau neuer
moscheen dacia wird gleichzeitig und
zwei riesigen gotteshäusern gebaut mit
den bauwerken werden geistliche geehrt
die während der diktatur getötet wurden
für den bau der moschee in scheinen
unbegrenzte mittel zur verfügung zu
stehen
es kommen nur teuersten materialien zum
einsatz fast überall im irak gebaut wird
ist auch korruption mit dem spiel
der irak gehört zu den drei korruptesten
ländern der welt
wir werden riesige maschinen hochgezogen
woher kommt das geld dafür
das sind natürlich öl gelder die von der
regierung verteilt werden um damit auch
politischen realitäten zu sichern also
das öl wird verkauft die milliarden
fließen rhein und die regierung verteilt
und damit werden politische realitäten
erkauft weil die hier hinter stehen ja
politische parteien der schiiten und
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich auch die
contractoren die eher ein riesen reibach
machen
100 milliarden dollar nimmt der ire hat
jedes jahr durch die ölförderung ein
ulrich teschner ist unterwegs zu den
ölfeldern im norden des landes
dieses gebiet wird von den kurden
kontrolliert die 17 prozent der
irakischen bevölkerung ausmachen
die regionalregierung sorgt dafür dass
die öleinnahmen in die infrastruktur
investiert werden
hier entsteht ein neues kraftwerk
ausländische investoren sind im
kurdischen norden iraks ausdrücklich
willkommen
der landesteil genießt eine große
autonomie und agiert in den meisten
bereichen selbstständig
überall schießen neubauten aus dem boden
die provinzhauptstadt erbil möchte zum
dubai iraks werden
[Musik]
das historische zentrum von abi wäre die
stadt nicht im irak würden sich wohl
hunderte von westlichen touristen
wertungen
die atmosphäre ist entspannt die polizei
hält sich diskret zurück
[Musik]
ulrich tilgner will von a bis
stadtpräsidenten der in deutschland
studiert hat wissen was die kurden
besser machen als der übrige irak
[Musik]
kurdische region kurdistan für den irak
als nation sieht der stadtpräsident
schwarz ähnlich wie 2005 könnte irak
wieder in einen bürgerkrieg schlittern
wie ernst die lage ist der ferne
korrespondent bei seinem besuch im
sunniten gebiet die stammesführer
bewegen sich nur im schutz schwer
bewaffneter bodyguards
geht unrichtiger in einem anderen
landesteil wechselte er aus
sicherheitsgründen die fahrzeuge und
auch seine mitarbeiter wie fahrer
übersetzer und techniker
die einzige möglichkeit als westlicher
journalist gefahren aus dem weg zu gehen
ist den schutz der jeweiligen
volksgruppe zu akzeptieren
man kann in dieser situation nur
arbeiten wenn man mit irgendeiner der
seiten unterwegs ist das sind
konfliktregion
es ist gefährlich kann man entführt
werden da drüben ist ein polizeiposten
allein kommt man nicht durch dann wird
man kontrolliert und dass es
funktioniert nicht allein die größte
gefahr ist die entführung ein
korrespondent hat einen marktwert von
etwa zwei millionen dollar ich habe sehr
genau studiert wie entführt wird und
entführung entstehen immer dann wenn
leute bestimmte routine entwickelt haben
das heißt niemand da wissen wo man wann
sich aufhält weil da schnappt die falle
zu
der konvoi des sunnitischen scheichs und
stammesführers ist unterwegs zu einer
großkundgebung gegen die regierung auf
dem autobahnteilstück bei ramadi jeden
freitag demonstrieren hier zehntausende
von unzufriedenen zu mieten
die stammesführer und geistlichen sind
entschlossen den druck auf die regierung
woche für woche zu erhöhen
[Musik]
ali hat dem als zu leimann ist der
mächtige chef des stammes durch die
entmachtung des sunniten saddam hussein
haben die sunnitischen stämme ihre macht
und ihre privilegien verloren und sie
sind entschlossen für ihre rechte zu
kämpfen
der scheich ist bereit unrichtigen ein
interview zu geben
er gibt sich vor der kamera diplomatisch
im moment können wir nicht sagen wir
warten ab welche entscheidungen die
regierung trifft sie hat es in der hand
die probleme zu lösen
erst wenn die regierung keinen erfolg
hat werden wir aktiv
der scheich wollte er eigentlich seine
leute an diesem tag nach bagdad
marschieren lassen hat sich dann aber im
letzten moment für die großdemo in
ramadi entschieden das programm beten
und protestieren
die forderung die regierung in bagdad
soll die sunniten an der macht
beteiligen protestieren ist männersache
unter den tausenden demonstranten gibt
es keine einzige frau
und wieder muss sich korrespondent
tilgner kontrollieren lassen
außer im kurdischen norden ist die angst
vor bombenanschlägen überall präsent und
massenveranstaltungen wie diese sind für
die terroristen aller seiten bevorzugt
die ziele die geistlichen geiseln in
ihren ansprachen die regierung in bagdad
[Musik]
sie haben unsere rechte und unseren
stolz vergewaltigt wir müssen uns
verteidigen
wer hand an unsere führer legt wird
seine hand verlieren
allah ist groß
[Applaus]
woher kommt dieser fanatismus ich würde
nicht sagen dass fanatismus das ist
entschlossenheit die leute haben ihre
macht verloren eine andere
glaubensrichtung stellt die regierung in
bagdad sie sind von der macht
ausgeschlossen
das heißt also dieses land ist
auseinandergebrochen und jetzt würde ich
sagen heute machen die sunniten der
wüste mobil wenn die sunniten nicht an
der macht beteiligt werden werden es
keinen kompromiss geben dann kann die
situation explodieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ulrich tilgner unser mann in irak wird
dafür sorgen dass dieser konflikt und
seine opfer nicht in vergessenheit
geraten
[Musik]